Let's see. I, uh,
last time I wanted to talk to you about,
uh,
more as a woman poet, uh,
as an American poet, uh,
and as a nature poet,
um,
I didn't get very far,
uh, with the ladder. Uh,
I started talking about
that long, uh, really, uh,
a tough palm and octopus
about Mount Rainier.
I'd like to go back there, uh, and to, uh,
work through a little bit of
that poem with you. Um, I, uh,
suggested that,
um,
this octopus that, that, uh,
more is writing about, um,
this mountain is that once something, uh,
other, something out there, uh, uh, a,
an emblem of the power of the
natural world. And on the other hand,
something that more identifies
with a certain qualities of,
of the mountain, uh, it's
energy. It's forced, uh,
the image of the octopus
itself. Uh, there,
the glacier on top of Mount Rainier
has I think, sort of eight arms. Uh,
and that's what she is,
um, uh, playing with, uh,
and I suggested that there's something
octopus like about Marianne Moore too,
with those long lines that,
that snake, uh, out, uh,
in seem to grasp onto all sorts of stuff,
uh,
producing this poetry of
collage and in multiple voices.
Uh, more. Uh, let me see
if I work through the,
the end of the poem with you,
uh, from around. Well, there's,
there's a long last stanza or paragraph,
uh,
whatever you would like to call it.
That begins on four 44
a at the bottom line,
one 61.
Um,
more is, uh, uh, talking about here,
uh,
maybe confusingly or unhelpfully
Greek aesthetics a while.
She's also talking about, um, the, um,
um, uh, creatures and, uh,
people that inhabit this place that
she's writing about Mount Rainier.
Uh, she, uh, she says on
the middle of four 45,
uh, about the, the Greeks.
It's all right. It's hard.
It's hard to quote from this poem.
It's hard to enter it at any point
because each thing is kind of connected to
the other. And to make sense of anything
you have to kind of work back. Uh,
she says, well, uh,
how do you,
how do you approach nature in a sense?
That's the great question of the poem.
A here the brochure is
telling us, well, we,
we shouldn't approach it with
guns, nets, uh, et cetera. Uh,
we won't be welcome there.
Um,
more was going to develop this idea
a little bit further. She says,
in a sense,
why bother putting all that down
more prodigious Lee includes
these quotations from, well,
you know, uh, hiking handbook,
uh, and then, uh, uh,
lyrical language like the spousal flower,
concise without a shiver,
uh,
shifting between these registers
of diction. Uh, and then,
um,
uh,
seeing the mountain as in that sense
as some kind of special flower,
a intact when it is cut,
and then she calls the mountain damned
for it's sacrosanct remoteness. That is,
she's, if she's saying
people, people, um, uh,
damn this mountain because it's
too high and far and remote to,
uh, climb sacrosanct remoteness. Uh,
that's a suggestive a phrase.
Uh,
it would seem to imply that,
um,
the mountain were with being
dammed for possibly, um,
uh,
what we would recognize as ethical
qualities in a person that is some kind of
eliteness, uh, in some
kind of reserve in fact,
properties that you might find
in an author like Henry James,
damned by the public for
decorum here, uh, more, uh,
makes the kind of strange
and Wild Association of the
mountain and Henry James,
uh,
as if the mountain where somehow I kind
of image of a that great sort of early
modernist,
a prose writer,
a damned by the public for decorum,
uh, that is damned for his,
uh, uh, elite, uh, posture,
the demands he placed upon the reader,
uh,
and his high level of decorum in writing.
Uh,
and then she corrects herself. She
says, not decorum, that's wrong,
but restraint. That's what James
exemplifies and that's what the mountain,
it seems exacts to.
Uh,
she continues and now she's talking about
Henry James. It is the love of, well,
and moving out of Henry James into,
into a general,
a general principle.
It is the love of doing hard things,
whether it's climbing the mountain or
reading late James that rebuffed and wore
them out the public, uh, public
out of sympathy with neatness,
neatness, uh, she, uh, arrives here, uh,
uh, substituting one
term for another. First,
I'm a remoteness than decorum,
decorum,
but restraint, not restraint
precisely necessarily or only,
but neatness, a kind of
aesthetic, uh, quality,
uh,
neatness of Finnish neatness of finish.
She says she exclaims those two
exclamation points following a,
as if, well, how did she say
them? Uh, is it, is it a,
in a spirit of exasperations with this
public that's worn out by the demands
placed on them by a certain kind of
writing or by a certain kind of mountain?
Uh, uh, I mean, uh, she, uh, uh, uh,
here mocking the idea of
a neatness of finish or,
or raising it as a kind
of banner and battle cry.
Now she moves back, uh,
again, uh, to the mountain,
a relentless accuracy. And
here she'll name it, uh,
the octopus.
Again,
relentless accuracy is the nature
of this octopus with its capacity.
For fact, she's talking
about the mountain. Uh,
but the mountain itself seems now to be a,
the embodiment of a certain kind of mind,
a certain kind of imagination
that grasps at and absorbs,
uh, and, uh, comes to assimilate fact.
And then, uh, she will,
um, turn herself over, uh,
in these closing lines to, um, uh,
a series of quotations
that described the mountain and do so,
uh,
with,
a kind of lyric exhortation
that that climbs
to the, uh, uh, romantic,
sublime and does so out in
this strange collage form.
It's an extraordinary kind of a
celebration and a declaration celebration,
uh, of, uh, the, uh, uh,
frankly savage forces that the mountain
both embodies and endures a at its
altitude. And, uh, as she does,
uh, she, uh, um,
suggests that there are,
uh,
similar forces of primal violence
and intensity that are contained,
uh,
and,
and indeed expressed in
the writing of Henry James,
uh, in the, uh, uh, aesthetic,
a project of a restraint,
uh,
that she herself,
engages in and that she calls us to and
calls the love of doing hard things,
whether that's climbing a
mountain or reading poems. Um,
this, um, uh,
closing passage is so powerful
and interesting because more,
uh, moves from, uh, a kind of writing,
which is often a ascribe to her or,
or identified with her
that his description,
precise observation of the natural world,
um,
uh,
kind of writing that is those frequently
seen as limited in its ambition and its
emotional power,
but amassed here in this sequence in fact,
uh,
takes on a kind of, um, uh,
well remarkable force and
in lyric a intensity, uh,
and makes more seem,
uh, uh, not at all. Uh,
like the restraint or prudish,
a virginal,
a poet that, um, uh,
many of her peers in subsequent
readers have found her to be.
Um, the, uh,
fastidiousness decorum
restraint. These, uh,
aesthetic and ethical values, uh,
in short are here attached to,
um,
uh,
powers and intensity that we don't
ordinarily associate with them.
Um, the volcano, uh, its whiteness,
uh, that's important. The white volcano
with no weather side because the,
uh,
the weather side of the volcano
has been broken off, uh,
in, uh, in ancient blast. Uh,
the volcano signifies a kind of,
um,
virginal force.
Uh,
it is a specifically female version of
elemental power and of the sublime a of
Emersonian self-reliance,
uh,
that comes to more,
via Emily Dickinson who
has her volcanoes to,
uh, self-reliance, uh,
by, by self reliance,
I mean, uh, more, uh,
hardy American insistence
on self sufficiency,
on independence and on originality.
And she is again, the most
radically original of all the poets.
We read the least like anybody
else. Uh, in this, interestingly,
despite her reliance on
quotation, uh, as, uh, her, uh,
uh, distinctive, um, uh, um, uh, medium
there, there's, uh, uh, um, powerful, um,
tradition of American romanticism
that's present in a more,
uh, with feminist, uh, ramifications.
Uh,
and it's interestingly,
in more joined to a modernist and
Ellie odic aesthetic of impersonality,
um, which, uh, we've seen, uh,
defined and Elliot's essay on tradition
and the individual talent and elsewhere,
uh, uh, Elliot's modernist
aesthetics were, were,
uh, attractive to more,
I think in part because,
uh,
Elliot's idea of impersonality was
compatible with female modesty,
uh, with, uh, Christian virtue. Uh,
let me, uh, turn to, uh, another
poem, a poem in your Ras Packet,
uh, as, uh,
helpfully concise as an octopus is long.
Uh,
and that's the pumps silence.
and you'll hear a kind
of echo of the lines. I
just read
another I think powerful poem.
Uh,
we saw more correct herself,
uh,
in an octopus saying,
not decorum but restraint.
Uh, here she says,
not in silence,
but restraint.
The deepest feeling she says,
shows itself in restraint shows itself
in restraints somehow by through a very,
the very act of restraint
is allied to an expressive
act of self disclosure.
Paradoxically, perhaps, uh,
the keys to our,
our deep identity are disclosed in some
of the ways in which they are withheld.
Uh, this is a theme from one
of the poems behind this poem,
which I've quoted, uh, uh, for you, uh,
on your handout from Longfellow,
from his palm of grief, uh,
called resignation by silence.
Sanctifying,
not concealing the grief
that must have way,
uh,
Moore's writing though,
remote in form from Longfellow or,
um,
uh, Emerson for that matter or homes. Uh,
another part we'll look at later
today, uh, is nonetheless, uh,
deeply involved in, in, uh,
19th century American poems.
Um, here, uh,
the poem silence itself seems to
be an example of what it's talking about.
That is,
it reveals something about more silently,
uh,
through what is not said or,
rather through the ways that what is
said gesture towards what is not a,
it's a poem that,
uh,
presumes to or presents
itself, uh, as speaking,
uh, for the poet, uh,
in, in the first person.
My father used to say,
well,
uh,
curiously more.
It's really not in at least an
explicit way speaking about her father,
uh, or what her father said. Uh,
more included in her
selected poems, notes, uh,
that disclose some of the sources,
uh,
that she was quoting from
borrowing from collaging with, uh,
and this particular, uh, poem, uh,
bears and note that,
uh,
attributes much of this
quotation to a certain, uh,
am Homans, uh, who is in fact a,
a distant relative of my
colleague Margaret Homans.
Uh, this, uh,
Miss Homans who sort of supplies most
of what's in the quotation there is not
Marianne Moore's father.
Uh,
so she's sort of borrowed words for
her father from a another source.
Uh,
and yet at the same time,
there's real poignant in
this expressive points. Uh,
more is, is, is telling us
something about her, her self.
She's being silent,
uh,
about the very early death
of her own father. Uh,
who was therefore in fact
a silent presence in her
life who told no stories to
her and said, no sings,
uh, who she couldn't.
In fact, quote in this manner, uh,
silence this short poem,
uh,
is it once a modernist poem that,
Elliot would have understood and admired,
uh,
and close to a 19th century
poems, uh, in its, um,
uh, ethical, uh, values and concerns.
Uh, it suggests too, I think
some of, uh, more is perhaps,
um, uh, ambivalent, uh,
certainly complex relationship to
her male peers. The topic that I, uh,
talked about last time with, um, um,
her poem a grave, uh, in
front of us, uh, which, uh,
it was connected to that
correspondence with pound.
I also mentioned a, her correspondence
with, with Hart Crane, uh,
uh, who, uh, um, um,
um, submitted his poems to
her in her role as editor, uh,
at the dial, uh, where she was in
fact in a very powerful position in,
in literary culture. Uh, and you know,
in certain ways, um, you
know, more had a kind of, um,
established authority and that
culture that crane never had. Uh,
here she had an important job
picking poems, editing, um, uh,
writing, uh, reviewing,
uh, and otherwise, um,
uh,
shaping the tastes a of American
readers through this important magazine,
the dial in yet at the same time more has,
um,
always has a kind of, um, uh,
marginal and a combative relation to,
uh, her, uh, major male peers, uh,
that is suggested in a grave and in her
irritation at the man who's blocking her
view. When you read, uh,
Elizabeth Bishop's memoir of
more, uh, Elizabeth Bishop,
uh, more as great protege, uh,
that, uh, really wonderful, um, uh,
a bit of both biography and autobiography,
uh,
that I asked you to read this, uh, for
this class called efforts of affection.
Uh, in there, you, you, you, you
see more interacting with the,
uh, male poets of her, uh, era, uh,
in interesting and comical ways.
Uh,
remember how some of them appear.
bishop notes the presence of, of, um,
answer a pound in, um, the
Moore's apartment, uh, when,
uh, more notes that, uh, uh, uh,
pound had burned the
banister with his cigar. Uh,
you know, he had to keep a cigar out of
Mrs. Morris, uh, uh, apartment and, and,
uh, you know, this sort of flaming
Phallic object, uh, you know,
Burns the staircase. Uh, there's a,
uh,
bishop also tells about seeing a
Valentine that Tsl Elliot had written to,
um, uh, uh, Marianne Moore, you know,
pound with a cigar and Elliot
with his Valentine. Uh, and,
and then there's an account
of a reading, uh, where, uh,
bishop, uh, heard more read
with William Carlos Williams,
uh, who, uh, Williams did,
made loud and realistic sea monster wars.
Uh,
you know, all of these
are kind of comic, uh,
in yet suggestive symbolic, uh, uh,
representations of Phallic
power through display,
uh, uh, in position, condescension, etc.
All of which more seem to
manage to keep it arm's length,
uh, through, uh, her distinctive, uh,
life choices, which entailed
living with her mother, uh,
in a, in an apartment in the
village. And then in, uh,
uh, on Cumberland Street
in, in Brooklyn, um,
Moore's literary life, her
imagination was, was rooted in this,
uh,
domestic space that Bishop
describes a powerfully,
uh, in, in a minute,
Lee and in her memoir,
a domestic space that had
all sorts of eccentric, uh,
rituals in charms,
uh,
at specifically female centered a world,
where, uh, more could admit, uh,
men like pound, uh, but where
a mother and daughter, uh,
could lead their culture literary
lives a very much on their own terms,
uh, without any men to answer to, uh,
Moore's home, uh, evoked
in, in bishop's essay
is a version you could say a of the many
shelters that you find a or shells or
protective armor that you
encounter in Morris poems. She,
you know, she admires is always fascinated
by armored animals. Uh, and they're,
they're, they're the kinds of, um, uh,
protection they seem to carry with them.
Uh,
the Pangolin is, is, is
one, uh, example, uh,
poems are also for more, um, uh,
forms of shelter, I
would say, uh, there, uh,
spaces in which she could construct
a world or parts of a world,
again, very much on her own
terms according to her own rules,
uh, like her home. Uh,
her writing was made,
uh, safe, uh, habitable,
uh, strong, uh,
pleasurable by virtue of the
limitations that, uh, uh,
she imposed upon herself.
Uh,
this is connected powerfully to a more
ethical ideas and to her feminism,
uh, Bishop writes about, uh, more in,
in that efforts of
affection, uh, well, um,
often with, with, uh,
expressing ways in which she
bishop as a young writer,
a chafed under the,
uh,
curious rules and disciplines
of the more household. Uh,
and yet,
uh,
she seems to understand the
power that was in those, um,
uh, rules for more. Uh, and, and, uh,
bishop defends Moore's,
um,
feminism specifically against
the kinds of, uh, attacks, uh,
made on more or dismissals of more,
uh,
by specifically sort of 60s and 70s,
a feminism.
Uh, Bishop says, um, you know,
uh,
do they know that that is a
feminist? Critics have more, uh,
that she was a feminist in her day,
uh,
or that she paraded with the suffragettes.
Uh,
once Marianne told me she climbed a
lamppost in a demonstration for votes for
women, which she did up there, what speech
she delivered, if any. I don't know.
Uh, but climb, she did in long skirt
and petticoats and a large hat.
Uh, she, uh, uh, bishop, uh,
continues now that everything
can be said and done.
Have we anyone who can
compare with Marianne Moore,
who was at her best when she made up her
own rules and when they were strictest,
the reverse of freedom. Uh,
she puts that as a question,
but it's not really a question,
is it? Uh, she's, uh, really, uh,
making a strong defense of more and of
the ways in which more used rules and
disciplines to exercise a
certain kind of freedom,
uh, and certainly to, uh, uh,
obtain a certain kind of power, uh,
more has her own version
of that, uh, statement,
uh, in that, uh,
essay at the back of the
anthology called humility,
concentration and Gusto.
Gusto is the sort of,
uh, uh, virtue of, of uh, let's say, uh,
uh, energy, uh, that,
that more approves in writing and
art above all in certain ways.
And she says at the bottom of the page,
uh,
Gusto thrives on freedom and
freedom in art as in life,
in art and life are always
versions of each other.
From war is the result of a
discipline imposed by ourselves.
Uh,
freedom in art as in life as the result
of a discipline imposed by ourselves.
I've been talking today
so far, uh, about, well,
forms of self effacement or, um, uh,
a restraint that one finds,
let's say thematically, uh,
in, uh, more where she is, um, uh,
impersonal in herself presentation
where she, uh, quotes,
creates her own voice by
quoting others where she, um,
uh, seems to, uh, withhold a,
the first person, uh, in,
in, uh, multiple ways,
the most obvious and, and, and vivid, uh,
and visible a form of the rules
that she sets herself is of course,
the way these poems look.
Uh,
an octopus and silence are very unusual.
Poems from where, because they are free.
Verse Poems, uh, by and large,
more Moore's poems are always,
uh,
organized into these complex
syllable counts, uh, and,
and the crazy patterns
that they, uh, produce, uh,
such as in, well, let's say,
uh, uh, just to look at the,
the steeple Jack or the
Pangolin on four 47, four 49,
um, or, um, uh, the paper Nautilus,
which I'll talk about in a moment.
Uh,
poems that have intricate
visual patterns on the page.
Um, they are, uh,
examples and instances of more making
a Peruvian rules in finding freedom in
them.
Uh,
they are also images of what she calls
in an octopus neatness of finish.
You could say they, they, they
present the poems as highly crafted,
almost a, not just visual,
but almost tactile objects.
Um, uh, ecstasy affords the, uh,
occasion, uh, expediency
determines the form. Uh,
she, uh, said about her
poems. Um, uh, again,
referring to those two different moments
of composition that she mentions in her
letter to pound that I talked
about last time, where, uh,
poems seem to come in a
kind of, uh, uh, Vadric, uh,
inspiration,
producing a certain pattern,
which then she determines quite
consciously to reproduce an extent.
Uh, the, uh, well let's, let's
look at the, the fish for a moment.
It's one of the most intricate and
distinctive and strangest on four 36.
And wait a minute. Whoa.
She's rhyming. Uh, the,
this is actually a rhymed poem to a
something you might not immediately here,
but yeah,
but look at it.
The fish wade through black
jade or an injured fan.
This is, this is really adding, um, uh,
an extra twist of the rules,
uh,
making the challenge of
writing that much harder. Uh,
and in so doing,
you might say to quote an octopus ex
expressing the love of doing hard things.
Um, more, uh, you
remember, remember pound,
uh,
his idea of the image.
He wanted to give you direct
presentation of the thing. Uh,
w what do they think about this?
Uh, hear you. You've got, um, uh,
poems that are so conspicuously
artificial that that stress, uh,
kind of discontinuity between form and
content that really present themselves as
arbitrary and constructed,
uh,
rather than given an necessary,
in this way more is, is, uh,
calling attention formally to the
contingency of all her statements and
utterances.
Uh,
she's also a calling attention to well,
to the fact that these are made objects,
uh,
and that they are the record
of their making their,
the record of a motive,
what I called the love of doing
hard things or, uh, which,
uh, more, uh,
just as often might
refer to simply as love.
Um, let me, uh,
uh,
point us to a couple other more poems,
um,
to a snail. For example, on four 46,
um, a, a, another short,
free verse poem,
uh,
in the written in the two or three year
period where she wrote Free Verse Poems
Around 1924,
uh,
if compression is the
first grace of style,
you snail habit, uh, Eh,
compression contractility,
uh,
these are virtues as modesty,
is a virtue in their forms of modesty.
What we value in writing in style is
the principle that has hit a kind of
animating motive, uh, that
informs what we have, uh, what,
what's there before us,
but which is necessarily
in some sense a silent, um,
uh, expressed through
restraint, uh, as it were, uh,
a compressed style such
as more as, uh, uh,
seems to compress and contain,
uh,
an important human motive.
Uh,
another poem about
the aesthetics of style, uh, that again
moves between principals and
art and principles in life. Uh,
is the poem in your Ras Packet
called when I buy pictures,
uh,
in which more says,
and then she gives a number
of different, uh, examples,
uh, further down, she starts
to generalize again. She says,
the shelters, the objects,
the artworks that more fines,
exemplary, uh, that she
wants to care about,
that she wants us to care about and
that she wants her poems to exemplify,
uh,
would be forms of acknowledgement.
Acknowledging the spiritual forces
that have brought them into being the
principles that are hit in them,
those forces about which they are
ultimately and can only ever be ultimately
silent.
Um,
the,
uh,
those spiritual forces, they, uh,
uh, they have a kind of energy,
they have light lit by piercing
glances into the life of things that,
that life of things. That phrase
that's Wordsworthian, uh, uh,
rich simple phrase.
Uh,
she means by it,
the life of things,
those things that have life and
that sense are not merely things,
uh, but creations that are infused
with, with creative force, uh,
artworks for more like God's
creation, uh, carry a, uh,
kind of burden of acknowledgement to,
uh,
give us access to an honor,
the forces that bring them into being,
uh,
the, the, uh,
really great poem I think on this theme
is the paper Nautilus. And let me,
uh, and our, uh,
contemplation of more
with this pump on four 51,
um,
it suggests a,
a way to understand the specifically
female artists that Moore is,
uh, is a, um,
it's a kind of shell
left behind, uh, that,
uh, protects the eggs of,
uh, the, uh, sea animal. Uh,
the, uh, the paper Nautilus. Uh, it's a,
it's a beautiful object. And, and I,
I wish I had, uh, the images of it to,
uh,
show you.
She begins in this first stanza,
maybe a little confusingly, uh, by saying,
in other words,
uh,
why does paper Nautilus
Make It's beautiful art?
That is its shell.
Does it do so for celebrity money?
Uh, uh, uh, tea time fame.
The Comfort of commuters? No, no. None
of these things. None of these, uh,
potential, uh, and base
motives for making art.
No. Uh, the paper Nautilus
Shell is something else.
The shell is first of all made not
for popular or genteel reasons.
Uh, it is, uh, specifically
a perishable because all art,
everything we make is perishable.
It is a perishable souvenir of hope.
It's,
it's such a beautiful phrase,
souvenir of hope. Uh, it is, uh,
a memory of our desire and wish
an aspiration for a future.
This is what the shell holes and contains.
It's not immortal. It's material.
It's delicate, imperishable.
It carries a memory of desire,
of hope that strives towards the future
in of a belief in the worthiness of
striving. It exemplifies the
love of doing hard things.
Carries this into the future.
Uh, the shell is maternal,
uh, or the sign of the
maternal, let's say,
rather it is a kind of
shelter for the future.
Uh, it carries hope, uh, in the
specific form of the creatures. Eggs.
Uh, this is, uh, this
is, you could say is a,
is a kind of revision of the earlier image
of female power is a volcanic, again,
there's something inside, uh,
of, of uh, great power, uh,
but it's another way of rendering
or imaging, uh, this power.
Uh, and, and you know, interestingly,
this creature like the,
the mountain, uh, is an octopus, uh,
viewed as,
as,
as if it were a poem or as a kind
of version of what a poem is.
You could say that the shell more
is writing about like a more palm,
a gets birth to
images of heroic action in her
poems are full of heroic characters.
Uh, some human, some many more animal, uh,
all of whom in,
in certain ways like Hercules
here are hindered to succeed. Uh,
and that's a wonderful and an
interesting phrase, hindered to succeed.
I think it means, uh, hindered, uh,
hindered to succeed in the sense
of held back or restrained,
but when something is, uh,
restrained in such a way,
it is restrained in order that it succeed,
uh,
hindered to succeed in that sense. Uh, uh,
restrained in order to succeed.
To overcome it's hindrance
to overcome itself,
self imposed rules and
guidelines or stands a forms, uh,
in order to, uh, produce the, um,
the future that it dreams of,
uh, ultimately those eggs,
they freed themselves and free
the shell at the same time. Uh,
the shell, uh, in its freedom,
uh, is, is a model of,
of the poem as a kind of
autonomous object. A thing
stands on its own impersonal,
uh, uh, taken away and
apart from the maker, uh,
it is strong and it's delicate.
It acknowledges and points
to the spiritual forces
that made it or illuminated
it.
Uh,
the paper Nautilus is actively revising
the famous poem by Oliver Wendell Holmes
that I've given you a copy of the
chambered Nautilus, uh, which, uh,
celebrates, um, the maker. You could say,
uh, uh, the, uh, and the, the energy
of the maker that, that, that,
that moves on to, uh, uh, it's
ever a more beautiful mansions,
uh,
more celebrates rather the made object,
uh, because it refers us back
to the process of making,
which is not a process of we'll only
a but a process in which the will is
hindered or restrained in which
aspiration meets resistance.
Look at the, the final lines of
the poem there. Very beautiful.
Uh, the shell is described as being a, uh,
having wasp nests,
flaws of white on white
and clothes laid ionic Khaitan folds.
And there,
you know,
she's seeing the white shell
as if it were a Greek marble
and it puts her in mind of the Elgin
marbles that decorated the Parthenon.
The shell is ultimately
compared to the, uh, a horse,
uh, which, um,
has lost its writer whose
arms no longer, uh, uh,
Gore around it and, and,
and restrain it. Uh, the,
the, uh, uh,
well there's an analogy between the
Horse in an implied absent writer
and the shell in the creature
that was once inside it.
And the poem in the poet who wrote it,
uh,
hope, uh, here at the end of the
poem is renamed love, uh, uh,
force, uh, imaged again
through a kind of silence,
through its absence or rather,
uh,
through the traces that of its continuing
presence, which are the, uh, uh,
traces that we see in the
strength and beauty of the object.
Uh,
which is,
I think ultimately the difference
between silence and restraint
that is
a
love is present in the palm.
It's not merely silent, uh,
it's present through it's
restrained expression,
uh, in what remains in
the poem in the Shell, uh,
in the Parthenon.
Horse is a,
is a kind of acknowledgement
of the spiritual forces. Yeah.
That
brought these objects into being,
well,
we will go on and talk about Morris,
great peer while a Stevens next week.